I can't even believe this is about to
happen there are like days of your life
where you just think this is as good as
it's gonna get and I know it's that for
Jeremy Jeremy Jeremy
[Applause]
ours looks just like this thank you John
yeah amazing look at this beautiful
romantic
piano we've got set up here sexy right
yes it's very sexy Jeremy oh Jeremy
Jeremy's naked on the piano
doing his or her best Burt Reynolds she
also loves music well let me
sing a song to Jeremy
that's right Jeremy there's been a light
change I've figured out what my melody
is
Jeremy
oh Jeremy
love your curves and all your edges
oh you're perfect imperfections
Jeremy
don't poop on me
you're mine and my beginning
if you don't poop on me I'm winning
remain
[Applause]
Jeremy you know this is as good as it's
ever gonna get
curious thank you you're welcome my
pleasure it's an honor I
I have to say while we were walking out
we were having a conversation about our
passion
um for beauty we're both Beauty junkies
and you have an extraordinary new line I
would love to talk about because I think
it is absolutely stunningly packaged
well made and if I thought I was going
to get skin care advice from you I'd be
like put it on me now give it to me now
and it has it has such a beautiful name
it's called loved one loved one that's
right how did you come up with that well
we really thought a lot about what we
wanted to convey with the name of this
brand we wanted to talk about the ritual
of caring for yourself loving yourself
and also the fact that you share that
with other people that you love because
so much of our skin care and our uh
preparing ourselves for the day happens
with our family the kids are in the
bathroom your partner's in the bathroom
you know and it's something you share
with your loved ones and so we thought
loved one was like the perfect way to
sum up what that meant and we made the
one a o with a little kind of raised
kind of superscript oh kind of give it
that Apothecary Vibe and make it feel
like you know you're you're going to
these you know great uh skin care
technicians who really understand the
body but also that it's all about love
and care for yourself yeah there is a
chemistry as well as the conveyance of
how we need to put into ourselves we've
got to take care of ourselves and so
many of us as you said about guilt we
think oh taking care of myself is
selfish you know we're all a little
afraid of that narrative and then the
older we get the more we get taught and
learn and realize how putting back into
ourselves actually benefits everybody
else which is what we're trying to do in
the beginning when we forgot ourselves
we need love our skin needs love and
care and we talk about caring deeply and
that's what our brand is all about well
and your family really represents that I
feel like from somebody who's been
watching you on the outside there's just
Beauty love and fun you know it's like
there's a lot of cooking too
[Laughter]
with your wife's food
cookbooks yes and pepper her mom yes
um her stuffed cucumbers is one of my
favorites dishes peppers
like I love I love your family I love
the cook we love to entertain we love to
bring people over to the house and
that's the way we show love to each
other also is by making food for each
other entertaining I like to cook for
her she likes to cook for me it's fun
well I know that people you know are
just giant fans of yours and there's
actually one person in particular okay
um we have her backstage you're
Whispering I know because all of a
sudden I'm realizing that I feel like I
should speak quieter
um would it be possible she has like
tried to go to your concerts are we
gonna surprise you he is a Super Fan
like do you think we could surprise her
let's surprise her really yes okay good
will you hide first am I jumping out of
a cake what am I doing by the way I
tried that one
take the cake out of plywood
if you hide we can go to Quick
commercial and I can bring her out here
and then I was thinking we could put her
on that massage table oh my and cover
her eyes with cucumbers are you gonna
start a facial and then I yeah and then
we could trade out oh what do you think
let's try it
foreign